joining us now are chief medical
correspondent dr john lepuc and senior
political analyst and 60 minutes
correspondent john dickerson good
morning to both of you
uh dr lapook i want to go to you first
and take advantage of that md
after your name if the president where
you're patient right now
everyone wants to know is it going to be
okay the course of this illness that's
what
we're curious about what would you be
looking for what should we be looking
for
in terms of knowing if the president is
going to be doing well or not so well in
this case
good morning tony you know statistically
he should do well right but he does have
from risk factors
of age and obesity and if there's one
thing we know about this virus the one
predictable thing about this virus is
that
it's unpredictable so i think he's going
to be watched very closely
are you going to look for any kind of
signs we all know what they are if you
know fever
cough and there are some other ones loss
of smell and diarrhea the most important
thing is
is he having any problem breathing in
terms of
other symptoms they're just going to be
watching him very very closely and in
terms of it being my patient i know he's
not my patient
but the trick here with the vip is you
treat the vip
just like every other patient you get
into trouble when you treat them
differently
we heard dr agus mentioned earlier that
the option for treatment is supportive
care what does that mean
what is meant by supportive care
supportive care just means making sure
they're well hydrated
uh you know that that they have good
nutrition and things like that because
there's nothing that's been proven
to help people in this situation yet uh
in the early course when they're still
feeling well
of course rem deservier and
dexamethasone have been shown to be
helpful in people who are sicker
it is possible that they could think
about using something like monoclonal
antibodies
to try to give to somebody very early in
the course but that's not yet been
proven uh to be effective or safe in
this situation
major garrett has made such a good point
this morning john lepuc when he says
we really need the white house to be
transparent here so what questions do
does the white house need to answer
to the american people today to let us
know how this is progressing and what is
happening
you know first of all we need to know
about the president's health and the
first lady's health
we just need to know total transparency
here we can take it
we're grown ups we just need to know the
facts it's reassuring even if it's
worrisome news it's reassuring to know
you're being
leveled with you're being told the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth and the other thing is to know the
incubation period
the incubation period is 2 to 14 days
that means if i get infected today
infected today i don't become infectious
until
2 to 14 days from now so then that's how
you figure out who was contact who was
infected
who was possibly exposed and they have
to do basic shoe leather public health
measures which is
find people who were contacts put them
in quarantine have them be in quarantine
and of course the president and first
lady
since they did test positive they'll be
in isolation is it troubling to hear
then that the president
after hope hicks had been diagnosed on
wednesday that he went to a fundraiser
in new jersey
and was around another group of people
there
yeah we we do know that you know it's
this concept and it's very hard for
people to get their arms around it
of the incubation period which means
that if hope hicks tested positive
on wednesday then she was probably
infected
at least 48 hours before then and then
on an average
five days from the time you're exposed
to being infected so do the math they
both could have been
exposed to the same person it's not
necessarily that he got it from hope
hicks is that they could have both
gotten it from somebody else
and both have been incubated he
incubated he could have been infected
but not yet infectious
and then once he became infectious he of
course could spread it to others yeah
why it's so important to wear a mask all
the time especially indoors yeah and
there are still so many questions that
how many people
in the white house are may have been
infected we don't know yet uh
john dickerson let me let me ask you as
as much as as the president seemed to be
flirting
uh with the coronavirus by not wearing a
mask and going to big rallies
what was your what was your first
thought when you heard the news
overnight well my first thought was we
didn't have to wait long into october
before we got our october surprise
my second thought was i i hoped
partisans wouldn't uh embrace their
worst instincts
in reacting to this and the third one
was that covid sleeps for no man i mean
kobet waits for no man i'm uh again the
president has downplayed the virus he's
mocked mask wearing as recently as in
the debate um
and yet the pandemic is relentless and
does not care where it goes and now it's
gone inside the most protected building
in america a lot of people will be
wondering uh this morning about the
president's ability to govern how do you
think this will affect
that well it depends of course
how bad the symptoms are and how uh just
physically how drained he is um you know
there are obviously protocols in place
here for both short-term
uh incapacitation should it ever get to
that and we're nowhere near that
um but also you know the white house has
a as an operating pattern
um but the question is if somebody tries
to take advantage of this there are a
lot of
of america's enemies circling around
this election at the moment
um and so uh it really depends both on
his condition and the challenges
he's faced with but there's nothing in
the evidence so far that would suggest
that this should be a particular problem
at this very moment
john we're all dealing with a lot of
uncertainty this morning and one of the
big ifs is
if the president takes a bad turn what
happens to the leadership in the white
house we've heard about the 25th
amendment can you tell us about
what that protocol is and and whether
it's been used before in american
history
well it has it has been used before in
very short duration
um when ronald reagan had a colonoscopy
when george w
bush did twice um and there's a and
and uh mike pence was um on standby at
least once to use it there is a process
for this there will be a run-up period
here where it could
where everybody can kind of figure out
exactly what the protocols are
um so there's a uh there's a way to
handle this should we ever get to that
pass which we're uh
which we're a long way away from at the
moment uh john labuk i want to go back
to you for a second we're hearing that
vice president mike pence and his wife
karen have both tested
uh negative that's what we're hearing
right now that is breaking news
but i have a question about i have a
question about joe biden
because it has been reported that he
tested negative that the president
tested negative on tuesday
before the debate is joe biden in any
jeopardy do you think
you know theoretically he could be in
jeopardy right
because remember that he tested negative
on tuesday but he could have had a low
level of virus there that didn't get
picked up
by the test so he shouldn't be really in
a lot of danger the one thing that i
thought of was that
the president certainly had a lot of
volume to his voice and the more you
the louder you are the more these little
aerosols can go out across
but i think probably uh he's not in in
big danger
but the vice president's not out of the
woods remember the two to 14 day
incubation period
so just because he tested negative today
he could still
have gotten it you know four five six
days ago
anything more than 48 hours ago from two
to 14 days and test positive
tomorrow or the next day so they have to
keep watching him and i suspect they'll
probably keep testing him
john dickerson as you said it didn't
take long for us to get the october
surprise
how if we can even anticipate at this
point do you think it's going to affect
the campaigns of both candidates
well it obviously takes president off
the campaign trail that means he's not
out there making the kind of news he
wants
that's also a physical drain on him when
you talk to his aides they talk about
those rallies as if they are
oxygen for him so he'll be sort of down
in that aspect and also it keeps the
campaign
this is why covid waits for no one it
keeps that issue right at the center of
the campaign
and the president's response to it which
is not something that he wants at the
center of the campaign because
the polls have consistently shown that
the country is disappointed with his
handling of the issue
uh and then the question is what happens
with the next with
the next debate how much is the uh vice
presidential debate taken over by this
issue
all of which um are complicated
questions and ones that the trump
campaign doesn't want to be talking
about
all right dr john lepuc and john
dickerson with the politics and the
prognosis this morning with this major
news thank you both